SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Let me just give
a sort of brief summary of
the book for those of you
who aren't familiar with
it and haven't read it.
"The Away Game" tells the
story of the largest talent
search in soccer history,
which was carried out
over the last 10 years
by the wealthy desert
kingdom of Qatar.
Over that period,
they held tryouts
for over five million
13-year-old boys, mostly
in Africa, looking for
soccer's next superstars.
It was led by a
Spanish scout who
helped launch Lionel
Messi's career at Barcelona.
And the process was over
1,000 times more selective
than getting into Harvard.
SPEAKER: Wow.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: So it
was an incredible story.
It was one that I really took
to when I first heard about it.
And that was back in 2007 when
the program first started.
I was living in Cairo--
actually saw a commercial on
TV for this gleaming new sports
academy in Qatar called
Aspire, did a bit of googling.
And it just so
happened that that
was when they launched
this program, which
is called Football Dreams.
And so I went over when the
first class of kids from Africa
were in Doha for
their final tryout,
wrote a story about
it for the AP.
And even then, I thought
it would be an amazing book
or documentary or
movie or something
but wasn't really in a
position to do it at the time.
And years passed.
I moved to Islamabad, as
you mentioned, and spent
a bunch of time having
great adventures,
embedding with
troops in Afghanistan
and with rebels in Libya.
But Football Dreams sort
of always stayed with me.
I always wondered what happened
to those talented African kids
who I had spent a few
days with years ago.
And so at the beginning of
2014, I decided to quit my job,
took a leap of faith, and
spent the next four years
traveling all over
the world, researching
and writing this story.
SPEAKER: And how did
you get introduced
to the scout, who was Josep?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Yeah, Josep Colomer.
He's the former youth
director at Barcelona.
He's the one who helped
launch Messi's career.
Messi was 16 when
Josep took over there.
And he promoted
Messi four levels
in one year, which is
something that had never
happened at the academy before.
And he's the one who gave Messi
his debut on the first team.
I first met Josep back
in beginning of 2008
when I went to Doha for
that story about the program
at the beginning.
He's a really
interesting character.
He comes from this medieval
town north of Barcelona
and has been obsessed with
finding the next generation
of soccer talent.
Even when he was a teenager,
he had a little futsal club
there in his little local town
and would spend his weekends
kind of canvassing the
local towns around him,
trying to find the best futsal
players and so eventually
made it all the
way to Barcelona.
He helped Brazil win
the World Cup in 2002,
so he's an
interesting character.
SPEAKER: So the
framework of the book
follows three kind of
aspiring professionals.
How did you decide
on those three?
How many players did
you research and end up
talking to to really
nail down your story?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah, it
was a difficult process
trying to choose which
players to focus on.
As you mentioned, I focus
on three African kids who
were found about 10 years ago--
two from Senegal,
one from Ghana--
and tell the story of where they
came from, how they were found,
and what happened
to them when they
were selected for this program.
And it was difficult to choose
which players to focus on
because so many of them
had incredible stories.
I mean, these were
all kids who grew up
playing on dirt fields
across Africa, often
barefoot or in plastic
sandals, dreaming
that someday some foreign
scout would show up
on the sideline
and point to them
and say, you're
marked for greatness.
And so you can imagine
their joy and surprise
when this Spanish
scout shows up who's
worked for one of the
biggest clubs in the world
and says he's going to take
them to a country they've never
heard of before, Qatar, and
make all their dreams come true.
But in the end, I held
interviews with over two dozen
of the boys in that program.
SPEAKER: Wow.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: And I
wanted to choose players
who had interesting stories
but different stories
so that they would be very
distinct for a reader.
And the three boys I chose--
Bernard, Diawandou,
and Ibrahima--
they come from
different backgrounds.
And also, they had
different trajectories.
They had different outcomes.
One of them-- I don't want to
give it away-- but one of them
made it all the
way to Barcelona,
where he was playing with
Messi and Neymar and Suarez.
The others sort of had
different levels of success.
And that was very
important for me,
to not just tell the story of
the boys who made it but also
the ones who didn't.
Because you realize that
the percentage of players
who actually make it all
the way to the top clubs
is infinitesimally small.
I mean, at the Premier
League academies in the UK,
the percentage of
players who make it
from the youth level to the
first team is a half a percent.
And these are kids who
are already in the best
academies in the world.
So you think about
a kid who grows up
playing on a dirt
field in Africa,
what's his percentage chance?
It's really small.
And so I wanted to also tell
the story of those kids who fans
never really hear about,
the names of the players
they never really learn.
SPEAKER: So let's talk a little
bit about that percentage.
And a lot of the--
big part of the book
in the scouting process
was the physical skills
versus the data analytics.
And you're really
scouting players
that have no video
footage on them
and not a lot of information
to base your decision off of.
What did you see was
how they were scouted?
And what were they looking
for in these players
to bring them to the academy?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah,
it's interesting.
One of the things
I do in the book
is I weave in a discussion
of the science of searching
for soccer talent.
There's been a lot of research
in the last 15 to 20 years
about what makes a
great player and what
scouts should be
looking for when
they're scouting young kids.
And the interesting
thing, as you mentioned,
is that they
shouldn't be focused
on physical characteristics.
Things like size,
strength, and speed really
aren't going to tell them
about a player's potential.
Speed is probably the most
useful of those variables.
But even speed is not really
going to tell you that much.
Technique is more important.
But the most important
factors are actually
the mental ones, things
like game intelligence,
vision, personality.
And game intelligence was the
most interesting one to me.
When I asked Josep first,
when I first met him,
what do you look
for in a player?
When you go and you're
standing on the sidelines
of a field in Nigeria
and you're watching
a bunch of 13-year-old
kids run around,
what are you looking for?
And he said, I
look for the player
who understands the
game, who understands
what the game is asking.
He said, there are plenty
of players who can dribble.
There's plenty of
players who can shoot,
but plenty of players, when the
game is asking them to dribble,
they shoot.
When the game is asking
them to pass, they dribble.
He said, but there are
certain players who always
make the right decisions.
And he likes to point
to Andres Iniesta, who's
this sprightly
midfield genius who,
for his whole career until
just now, played for Barcelona.
He likes to say that
Iniesta isn't big.
He's not fast.
He's a good dribbler,
but not the best.
He doesn't score goals.
But he always makes
the right decisions.
And so he was looking for
that game intelligence.
And interestingly enough,
although Josep himself
didn't know the
science behind it,
there's been a bunch of
research into game intelligence.
And what they found
was that in children,
game intelligence develops not
so much through formal games
and practice, but
through pickup soccer,
through the kind
of street soccer
that these kids in Africa and
South America play so much of.
And so he intuitively
knew that if he
went to a place like
Africa that there
were a lot of kids with that raw
talent that he was looking for.
And it was interesting to see
that the research actually
backed that up.
SPEAKER: Let's talk a little
bit about the academy.
A lot of investment
went into the academy.
But it's kind of an
interesting dynamic on timing.
And it seems like they were--
kind of had two routes
for the players,
either to go get them
to become professional
when they turned 18,
or it seemed like,
to play for a national team.
Did you get a sense that with
the timing of the 2022 World
Cup and the age being
kind of the right fact
that that might have
played a little piece
into them wanting to play
for the Qatar national team?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Yes, so that actually
did-- that ended up
playing into it somewhat.
But the program actually
started before Qatar decided
to bid for the World Cup.
And the background
to the program
is that it starts with
one of the richest
men in the world, a guy named
Sheikh Jassim bin Hamad Al
Thani, who's a member of
the Qatari royal family.
And he decided
nearly 20 years ago
that he was going to
make it his mission
to produce a world-class
Qatari national team.
In fact, he was so
passionate about soccer
that he was heir to the
throne at the time, of Qatar.
He gave that up to his brother
and sort of threw himself
into this project
wholeheartedly.
And the first thing he did was
he spent a billion dollars.
And he built Aspire
Academy, which
is possibly the most high-tech
sports academy in the world.
The signature feature of Aspire
is the largest air-conditioned
sports dome in the world, which
is the width of the Eiffel
Tower laying on its side.
So it's absolutely massive.
You can imagine what it was
like for these African kids
when they showed up for
the first time in Doha
after running around
on dirt fields
and then seeing
this massive dome.
So even though Qatar only had a
few hundred thousand citizens,
which is pretty tough
to think about producing
a world-class national
team, he had money to spend.
He wanted to do it.
So he spent $1 billion.
He built Aspire.
He hired all the best
scouts and coaches.
And the first thing they
did was held tryouts
for every boy in Qatar.
Because you can do that if
you only have a few hundred
thousand citizens,
quickly realized
they didn't have the
population necessary to produce
a world-class national team.
And that's when they ended
up launching Football Dreams.
He connected with Josep Colomer,
who had been at Barcelona.
And they set off.
They actually invited Pele over
in 2007 to launch the program.
And their stated purpose for
doing this was just, well,
they wanted to go find
players in Africa who
were much better than the
players in their academy
so that those
African players could
train with their local
players and improve
the level of
training, which would
make the local players better.
But Qatar has a long
history of using its wealth
to lure foreign athletes into
taking Qatari citizenship
and competing for the country
on the world's highest stage.
They've done it for
Kenyan sprinters,
Bulgarian weightlifters,
my personal favorite,
a Chinese chess grandmaster.
And so I think at the
beginning of the program,
they had this idea
that they would
go find the best of
the best in Africa,
bring them, give them
Qatari citizenship,
and they would play for Qatar.
And eventually, once they won
the right to host a World Cup,
that became even more important.
But as the book describes,
it didn't exactly
play out as they had planned,
so it became a more complicated
endeavor than they imagined.
SPEAKER: And so you
mentioned that this
is one of the top
world-class facilities.
What was that like
for the first group
that came over that, as you
mentioned, played on dirt?
A lot of them
didn't have cleats.
And coming into just
this incredible facility,
what was that transition like
to just the day-to-day life
and then also the ability to
train at such a higher level?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Yeah, I mean again,
it was staggering
for them to show up
for the first time at Aspire.
I mean, one of my favorite
quotes in the book
is Diawandou, one of
the players I focus on,
who is this defender
from Senegal.
The first time he walks
into the dome, he says,
even if I don't make it,
I want to be buried here.
I mean, it was just like nothing
he could have ever imagined.
And so these kids, they
had to adjust to that.
I mean, these are kids
that many had never
had hot water showers
before or never
been in an elevator,
things like that, which
for us, are pretty commonplace.
But for them, it was a
totally new experience.
And it took some time,
too, adjusting to that.
But they had to adjust
because they needed
to focus on what was going
to happen on the field, which
was they were about to be put
into a tryout with the elite
of the elite from
the rest of Africa.
And in order to have any hope
of staying at the academy,
they really needed to perform.
And so there was a lot
of pressure on them.
A lot of these kids, they came
from pretty poor families.
And so their families saw soccer
and saw them as the best ticket
to sort of a better life.
And so it was a lot of pressure
on them at a young age.
SPEAKER: And they
had some success
as a team in the academy.
Can you talk through?
I know they played the
Real Madrid, Barcelona,
some of the best European
teams in the world.
Could you talk about
maybe one of the--
I think you highlight in the
book one of the great games
and some of the
wins that they had?
What did you notice?
And what did you think was
kind of the coolest experience
for them?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah,
I mean these kids,
they sort of blew the
soccer world away.
They would go play
at these tournaments.
Nobody had ever heard of them.
I mean, the amazing thing
about Football Dreams
is even though it's massive--
again, they held tryouts
for five million kids--
a lot of folks in
the soccer world
had never heard about it before.
So these kids would
show up at a tournament,
and AC Milan or
Barcelona or PSG would
be looking at their
schedule and saying,
oh, we're playing
Aspire Academy.
Who are these guys?
Africa and Football Dreams?
Never heard of them.
And then get wiped
off the field by them.
I remember I was with the coach
of the AC Milan's under-16 team
at this tournament that's
held in Doha every year
called the Al Kass
tournament, which
is one of the biggest youth
tournaments in the world.
And I saw him watch the
Football Dreams kids
play for the first time.
And his jaw just dropped, and
he was like, who are these kids?
But one of my favorite
stories along those lines
was back in 2011, they played in
this tournament called the Milk
Cup in Northern Ireland,
which is, again,
one of the biggest tournaments
in the world for youth teams.
And they crushed everyone.
And in the final, they beat
Manchester United five to one.
And one of the players I
focus on, Ibrahima Dramé,
who is this sort of tall,
strapping striker from southern
Senegal, scored a hat
trick in the final.
He was the highest scorer
in that tournament,
as he was many other
tournaments he played.
And so that tournament was
very emblematic of they
would go, be totally
unknown, and then just wipe
all of these major
clubs off the field.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Now there was a lot
of money that came
into the investment of this.
Did they feel they got
a return on the academy?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: I
mean, if you ask them
whether they thought
it was a success,
they would say yes,
because it's their program.
But they spent upwards
of $200 million
on this program over a
period of 10 years, which
sounds like a lot
of money to us,
but for Qatar, actually,
is not that much money.
That maybe is a day of oil
and gas revenue for them.
So it's not a huge investment.
I think it depends on what
lens you look at the program
through.
If you look at it on a
purely scouting basis,
they produced some players
who made it to big clubs.
A lot of their players
have played for their youth
national teams in Africa.
And so you could kind
of debate whether or not
it was successful.
I think for that
amount of money,
you probably would have
wanted even bigger players
to come out of it.
But you can debate that.
The other thing that
they really focus on
is they say this was a
humanitarian program.
They say, our focus
was to try and help
kids in Africa who
wouldn't get the chance
to become professionals,
top professionals,
because they don't
have the development
opportunities at home.
I think it's a harder
case if you look at it
as a humanitarian program.
I mean, there were
definitely kids
whose lives were transformed.
But spending $200
million on what
ends up being a very
small number of kids--
I mean, every year,
they held tryouts
for about 500,000
13-year-old boys.
And they chose the top 20.
And then from that 20, you know
that only a small percentage
of those are actually
going to succeed,
because it's so hard to
choose which kids at that age
are going to be
top professionals.
And so $200 million on a
very small number of people
does not necessarily make the
greatest humanitarian program.
And so I think from
that perspective,
it maybe doesn't look so great.
SPEAKER: So you bring up age.
And I think the most
interesting parts of the book
and, personally, the
part I found fascinating
was that there is
this question of age
and about are these
kids actually 13?
And it seems like you
uncovered that in some cases,
there might not be.
How many players did you
notice that the age might not
have been true?
And then what was the
most egregious 13-year-old
that you saw?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: So
yeah, so age cheating
is a big problem in soccer--
in youth soccer in Africa,
and actually not just in
Africa, but other parts
of the developing world as
well, where kids will often
say that they're much younger
than they are to make it
seem like they're
better than they are.
I mean, imagine
putting a high school
senior in a game with a bunch
of elementary school kids.
And you can imagine
that the high school
senior would seem really good.
But actually, he's just older.
And so this is so
widespread in Africa
that you'll hear coaches
talking about a player,
and they'll say, he's 18
but his football age is 13.
And so I had heard, I
knew conceptually this
was a problem, but I
spoke to Aspire about it.
And they said, oh, yeah.
No, we've got it covered.
We do our own medical
scans on the players
once they get here
to Doha to make sure
that they're the right age.
And so FIFA, what they use
is they do a wrist MRI,
because you have growth
plates in your wrist.
And their scientists say that
if the growth plates are fused,
there's a 99% chance
a player is over 17.
So that's what they use at,
say, the under-17 World Cup.
And so Aspire told me,
we've got it covered.
And I thought, OK.
Well, it's not going
to be a problem.
And that's a huge leg
up for them in them
trying to find future
stars in Africa.
But then I went to Africa for
one of my big research trips.
I mean, I spent about five
months in West Africa in total.
And I started getting the sense
that these players weren't
necessarily the age
that they were saying.
You'd get comments.
You'd hear certain things.
And so one of the moments for
me that really kind of stood out
was I was talking to
a player named Yobou
Thome, from the Ivory Coast.
And I thought he was going to
be one of the central characters
in my book.
He has a fascinating story.
When he was selected to go
to the final tryout in Doha,
they discovered he
had a heart defect.
And they did surgery on him.
And he recovered.
He became the captain of
the under-17 Ivory Coast
national team, took them
to the World Cup in Mexico,
and then at that
tournament was lured away
by a German agent who
promised him glory in Europe.
And he ended up having
a very difficult time.
So I thought, this
is an amazing story.
He'll be one of my
main characters.
And so I went to Abidjan
to spend a few weeks
with him and his family.
And so I was talking to him
and one of his youth coaches
from Abidjan.
And I asked the youth
coach, so what age was Yobou
when you first saw him play?
And the youth coach said
to me, oh, he was 13.
And I turned to Yobou, and
I said, but wait a minute,
weren't you 13 when Aspire
came and held tryouts?
And he goes, oh, yes,
I was also 13 then.
And so then I thought,
OK, well, he wasn't 13.
But what age was he?
And it is very
difficult to figure out
exactly what age these
kids are, because everyone
is trying to deceive you.
I mean, they are.
Their parents are.
Their coaches are.
Sometimes federation
officials are,
because they know that they
might get a little bit of money
if a kid makes it.
And so somebody told me the only
way to really determine the age
is to go to the kid's
elementary school
and figure out what was the
birthday that was written down
when the kid started
school at the age of five.
And so I went to his
elementary school in Abidjan.
And I managed to
convince the principal
to let me look through
these handwritten records
that they had.
That had this big stack
of handwritten logs
that were sort of
tattered and dusty.
And so I'm flipping through
all these-- took me forever.
I finally find Yobou Thome.
And I kind of get
to his birthday,
and I do the math in my head.
And all of a sudden,
I kind of like start.
And I realized that he
wasn't 13 when he tried out
for Football Dreams.
He was 21.
And I've seen pictures
of him at the tryout.
And he doesn't
necessarily look 13,
but he doesn't look 21, either.
So the problem was is
that these European scouts
that went and did the
scouting in Africa,
I mean, they knew soccer.
They came from Barcelona.
They came from Espanol.
They came from Atletico Madrid.
So these were guys
who knew the sport.
But they'd never really
scouted in Africa before.
And so they would get
sold a bunch of stories
by the locals, one of
which was, oh, African
kids just mature a lot
faster than European kids do,
when actually, the
opposite is often
true because of malnourishment.
African kids, on average,
tend to be smaller
than kids in Europe
of their same age.
But these scouts didn't
really know this.
So they would just get
sold a bill of goods.
And so the players
that they were picking
were not always as good
as they thought they were.
SPEAKER: And
there's another kind
of piece to that that
you kind of brought up,
which is they have the local
coaches that are really
trying to get them to
become a professional
so they can take a little bit
of the money, a cut of that.
It seems like there's a little
bit of illicit trade happening.
Do you see that?
Was that a big part
that you uncovered?
And then what do
you see the soccer
world doing to combat that?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Yeah, I mean, it's
a huge part of that
whole industry there.
I mean, basically, you'll
have these guys who
are local coaches--
I say coaches in quotation
marks because they're not really
coaches.
They're just local guys from
the neighborhood who might
have an interest in soccer.
Maybe they played a
little bit themselves.
And they'll sort of prowl
the schoolyards, looking
for the best young kids, and
buy them at a very young age.
And so then they own
their registration.
They own their license.
And so if a club ever wants
to take that kid to Europe,
they're going to have to buy
that license from that coach.
And that can create some
really difficult situations,
because the coach's
interests are not always
the same as the kids' interests.
And one of the players
I write about in my book
ends up in conflict
because of that.
And there's this big
problem of this sort
of illicit trafficking of young
players from Africa to Europe.
FIFA put in some
rules in the last sort
of 10 years, 15 years, that
said that players aren't allowed
to go from Africa
or anywhere else
to Europe until they're
18, because they've
been trying to cut down on
this, although it continues
to happen.
And there's a lot of stories
of kids getting there
and either tryouts
not materializing
or them not making it and
ending up living on the street,
either because they
don't have the money
to go back or they're
so humiliated because
their parents spent their whole
savings to get them over there
that they don't want to go back.
And so there's been an effort
to combat this problem.
But it's definitely
still a big problem.
SPEAKER: And so part of
what it seems like Aspire
did to into combat that
is acquired a Belgian club
as a way to have a
path for these players
to be professional.
Did you see that that was
a successful practice?
Or was everyone
still trying to get
to the big European, Barcelona,
Madrid type of clubs?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah, the
acquisition of the Belgian club
was one of the most
interesting parts of the story.
Because what happened was Josep
Colomer, the Spanish scout,
he was trying to figure out,
what do I do with these players
when they finish the
academy at the age of 18.
Because it's very
difficult for most players
to make the jump from
18 to a top club.
They need more
experience at sort
of a lower professional level.
And so, when you're
Qatar, you just
go out and buy a
team for the kids.
And so they went to
Belgium, and they
bought this little
second division club.
And it was one of
the most fun parts
of the research process for me.
Because, you can imagine,
this town of 20,000 people,
Eupen, the residents wake up one
morning and their local team,
the Pandas, is owned by
some Middle Eastern country
they've never heard of and
filled with African teenagers.
And so it created quite a
bit of turmoil in the town.
And so I went and spent
several weeks there.
My wife was with me at
the time because she
speaks French and was
able to translate for me.
And it was fun.
We would walk down the street,
and it's the kind of place
where after you've
been there a week,
everyone knows who you are.
And so we would walk
down the street,
and they'd be waving at
us, calling us Mr. and Mrs.
Washington, DC.
And you go into a bar,
and you can't buy a beer.
Like, as soon as you sit down,
there's one in front of you.
And they just want to talk about
what's going on with the club.
One of the local
supporters' groups
boycotted the first
year because they
didn't agree with
Qatar owning the team,
although, then they discovered
that these African kids were
a whole lot better than the
players that they had before.
And so they did come around.
But it did end up being
a good jumping-off point
for some of the kids to
bigger clubs in Europe.
What ended up being
more of a problem
is that there was only so much
room on this team in Belgium
for players.
And so they could only take--
after the first year, when they
sent a bunch of the players
there, they could only
take a few players
per year, the absolute
best of the academy.
And so there were a
whole bunch of others
who didn't really have an
established route into Europe.
And so that created a
whole lot of problems.
SPEAKER: So let's talk
about where are they now.
Are any of the, I guess, two
dozen that you researched--
how many have made it?
And are any playing in
the upcoming World Cup?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: So the
ones I focus on in the book,
they aren't at the World Cup.
Again, they've had varying
degrees of success.
One made it to Barcelona.
One other made it into Europe
sort of at a more middle level.
And one had less success and
is actually back in Africa.
There are a couple of players
from the program in the World
Cup this summer-- one for
Senegal, and one for Nigeria.
There would have
been another one
for Nigeria, a player
who's very good,
named Henry
Onyekuru, who plays--
he's owned by Everton,
although he was loaned out
to Anderlecht last year.
He was the top scorer in the
Belgian league the first year
he played in the Belgian league.
And he'd be in the
World Cup this summer
but he hurt his knee.
So he's not going to be there.
And so I've definitely--
I've kept in touch with all
of the boys who I write about.
The one who hasn't
had much success,
I'm actually trying
to figure out
a way to help him financially.
I'm paying for his kid's
school fees right now
and trying to help
him get a job,
because soccer really
isn't going to work out
for him at this point.
And so that's-- the
difficult thing is, for me,
one of the most impactful parts
of the story was the players
who didn't make it, because you
see how difficult it is then.
They get so close to the sun,
and then they fall all the way
back down to Earth.
And it can be very
difficult for them
to figure how to put
their lives back together
and find a new path forward.
SPEAKER: And what about the
state of Aspire and Football
Dreams?
Is it still progressing forward?
How is it today?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: So they
suspended the search
at the end of 2016.
They said they wanted
to evaluate how it's
gone for the first 10 years.
They're still running
the academy, both in Doha
and they also have
a satellite academy
where they train Football
Dreams kids in Senegal.
That's still going.
They still have the
club in Belgium.
And so they're still hoping
to produce future superstars
from the program.
SPEAKER: And now
that you've written
a book on soccer, what's
your World Cup prediction?
You're an expert now.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Yeah, well, I guess
I have this sort of category
of what I would like to happen
and then what I
think would happen.
I mean, I'm a big Messi fan.
So I would love to see
him win a World Cup.
I don't think it's
going to happen.
Their team is not very good
and totally imbalanced.
They have amazing strikers
and not much else.
I think everyone would love
to see Iceland make a run.
It's interesting, Iceland is
about the same size as Qatar
when you look at the
number of citizens.
So it's incredible that
Iceland produces the stars
that it does in
Europe and that it's
made it into the World Cup.
And then another
sort of emotional one
for me is Egypt, because I
lived in Cairo for three years.
And they've been out of
the World Cup for so long
that it would be wonderful
to see them make a run.
I'm hoping Mohamed
Salah's shoulder
is OK after the
Champions League final.
And so those are my categories
of who I'd like to win.
Who I think will actually win--
Brazil's very good.
Germany's very good.
And I think it will probably
be one of those two.
But Belgium is very good.
Spain is very good.
France is very good.
So I think it's going
to be a great World Cup.
And I think if it's going to
be a Brazil-Germany final,
I'd like to see Brazil win.
I know it would be a kind
of collective bit of therapy
after the last World Cup if they
could they could beat Germany.
But it will be fun,
whatever happens.
SPEAKER: Great.
So getting away
from the book, you
were a foreign correspondent
for many years.
I'm sure you saw
some crazy stuff.
What's the wildest story you
have from your time living
overseas?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah, I mean,
it was a lot of crazy times.
Again, I spent a bunch
of time in Afghanistan
and a bunch of time in
Iraq with the troops.
But probably the most
insane was I spent a month
with the rebels in
Libya on the front lines
when they were fighting Gaddafi.
And it was like "Mad Max
and the Thunderdome."
I mean, these guys,
they didn't really
know what they were doing.
They'd stripped rocket launchers
and anti-aircraft weapons
off Soviet attack
helicopters and bolted them
in the back of pickup trucks
and were driving around.
They could never bolt the rocket
launchers on tight enough.
And so when they started
firing, the rockets would--
it would get loose.
And the rockets would be
firing all over the place.
And you'd be out there, and
all of a sudden, Gaddafi
would just start firing
artillery at you.
And so the desert
would just erupt
with artillery shells hitting.
And you'd have to dive
in the back of a car
and just speed off,
hoping not to get hit.
And so that, for me, was
probably the craziest
just because it was
so unpredictable.
SPEAKER: Wow.
AUDIENCE: What's up, man?
Ricardo.
Thank you for coming,
definitely going
to pick up the book as well.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Just one
quick comment--
you didn't mention
Colombia in your favorites.
Not offended, but keep them
on your radar, everyone.
One thing that I'm interested
in is understanding
your perspective in terms of
what kind of role technology
can play in the way that
the game is experienced
in developing worlds and the way
that people are finding talent
and stuff like that.
Because obviously, Google is
a technology company first,
and obviously
trying to help out--
move humanity in the right
direction and everything
like that.
But I'd just be interested
to hear your take on trends
that you're seeing and ways
that you envision technology
potentially being
able to help things
from a football standpoint.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah.
That's a good question.
Yeah, I think it's very
interesting, especially
from a scouting
perspective, what's
happening with technology.
I mean, obviously, everybody's
familiar with "Moneyball"
and the sort of revolution
in data analytics
when it comes to sports.
Soccer has actually
been somewhat
of a laggard in that category.
It's sort of dragged its feet
into the data analytics age.
But there's definitely
been progress.
There's a focus on
more useful statistics
when it comes to games,
things like expected goals,
expected assists.
But the problem with a
lot of the technology
and the data analytics that's
been done in soccer so far
is that it was all
very ball-focused.
So it was focused on things
that happened with the ball,
whether that be goals or
shots or assists or dribbles
or tackles.
But the reality is
that 99% of what
happens in a game in soccer
happens off the ball.
And so if you're not
taking that into account
when you're doing
your data analysis,
you're basically missing
the whole ball game--
pun intended.
And so what they're
starting to do now,
because they have so
much tracking data
of both the ball
and the players,
they're starting
to be able to look
at what's happening
off the ball, which
is incredibly important.
And in one of the ways
it's most interesting
is what I talked about before
in terms of game intelligence.
The ability to make
split-second decisions
in a dynamic environment
is the hallmark
of sporting genius in general
and very much in soccer.
And so they're
starting to come up
with more sophisticated
algorithms using
all of this tracking
data that can spit out,
basically, intelligence
scores for players,
are players making
the right passes,
the right runs,
the right dribbles,
given not only what's
happening on the ball,
but the position of all of
the players around them.
Now, that's only happening at
the very top level right now.
And even then, it's
sort of just starting.
And it's going to take
some time for one,
them to make the algorithms
more sophisticated
because it's very
complex, and also
for them to be accepted
by scouts and coaches
in the sport.
But eventually,
that will happen.
And eventually, the
technology will become cheaper
so that it will filter
down to the youth level.
And I think it's going
to be fascinating
when that does happen.
Because I can imagine a
scenario where let's say
you recreated this same
scouting project some years
in the future.
And you have a Josep
Colomer figure standing
on the sidelines who maybe
puts a drone in the air that
is filming all of
the kids and the ball
as the game is going
on that then spits out
game intelligence scores to
his iPhone or his Google phone.
And he's able to
evaluate right there what
he's seeing in front of him.
So it will be interesting
to see once we start
to be able to get quantitative
measurements of game
intelligence how much of an
impact that has on scouting.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a
lot for the talk.
You slightly mentioned about
the kids who went to the academy
but then didn't make it.
So I was wondering, can you
talk about that a little more,
like what happens with kids
when they return to Africa?
Are there any other programs
they can take part or any clubs
in Africa?
What happens?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah, again,
he made it to the academy
but then had to
go back to Africa.
And unfortunately, it's
one of the real weaknesses,
I think, of the program that
there wasn't really much
for him to go back to.
Most of these kids, they didn't
see playing back home in Africa
as success.
I mean, the best players
in most leagues in Africa
are earning a few
hundred dollars a month,
which you think about that
compared to what a player will
earn playing in even the most
low-tier European league,
it's just absolutely nothing.
So all of them want to travel.
In fact, that's one
of the reasons why
I called the book
"The Away Game,"
is because that's
how they view it.
They all want to get away.
They all want to get
to Europe and play.
And so when they get back,
they don't necessarily
want to play in Africa.
Or if soccer just doesn't
work out for them at all,
they don't really
have much to fall back
on because although they went
to school during the academy,
education really wasn't
a focus for most of them.
They admitted
themselves that they
would use class time
to sleep because they
were tired from training.
And so unfortunately,
they really
struggle trying to
find a new way forward.
And this isn't necessarily just
a problem with this program.
I mean, a lot of academies
around the world, the kids
don't really focus
on a plan B enough,
because they all
think they're going
to be the ones who make it.
And you have to have
that self-belief
if you're going to get
through a process that
is as competitive as it is to
make it in professional soccer.
But the reality is only a
small percentage of them
would make it.
And so a lot of
them, they struggle
to figure out a plan B once
it doesn't happen for them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
coming-- really appreciate it.
The book sounds fascinating.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm really looking
forward to reading it.
So my question is what do
you think about the state
of African youth soccer?
If you compare the
talent in Africa
to the talent in a South
America or a Europe,
do you think the talent
is at equal levels?
And do you think that there is
a gap in the players making it
to Europe?
Is it the scouting?
At what point in the
pipeline does it break down?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah.
That's another good question.
The raw talent is definitely
there, no doubt about it.
It's as good as anything
you'll find anywhere--
South America, anywhere else.
The gap is in the
development system
for both identifying and
developing young soccer talent.
They don't have and
haven't historically
had the academy infrastructure
that you would see in Europe.
And the club teams
haven't historically
focused on players much
younger than sort of 15, 16.
You're starting to
see that change now
with some academies
that have sprouted
in the last sort of 10 years.
One academy in particular,
called Right to Dream, in Ghana
is having good success.
And there's others that have
started in that same mold.
And so I think that's
one of the reasons--
Pele famously predicted in 1977
that an African country would
win the World Cup by 2000.
And that hasn't happened.
The farthest an African team
has gotten is the quarterfinals.
And I think a big problem
is that the problem
of the lack of
youth development,
again, because at least
officially, players
aren't supposed to be going
to Europe until they're 18.
There needs to be a good
development infrastructure
for them to succeed in Europe
once they reach the age of 18.
And that hasn't existed.
I think as you have with
a lot of different sectors
in Africa, not just soccer,
lack of resources and corruption
is a big problem as well.
You often see teams get to
the World Cup from Africa.
And then players are boycotting
because they're not getting
paid what they promised.
And it can just be real mayhem.
And it can impact their
performance on the world stage.
And so that's been a
big problem as well.
AUDIENCE: So I think
I'm one of the 99.5%.
I played international soccer as
a kid, played in the Milk Cup.
The question I have is when
you go through the evaluation
process where there's five
million kids through the years,
a lot of the tools that
we have and metrics--
and everybody at Google
knows about metrics--
are about the physical, right?
So the drone stuff's
already there.
We've already got the heart
rate monitors, we got already.
But in my own experience--
I'm still involved here.
I coach at Ehrenbern, and
the difference can sometimes
be emotional intelligence.
Was there any part
of the process
through that kind of
vast number of kids
that actually looked at
that, or was the focus purely
on the physical?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
So in this program,
they didn't focus on emotional
intelligence or personality
in any structured way.
It was a more informal thing
of spending time with the kids.
But there are attempts at
some of the top academies
to look at emotional
intelligence and personality.
And so for example,
at Manchester City,
there's a woman
named Carol Dweck,
who was at Stanford, who
did a lot of research
on what she called the
growth mindset in children.
Sort of basically does a
child have a growth mindset
or a fixed mindset?
Growth mindset means that you
don't think your abilities are
sort of fixed in stone.
You think you can develop
them with hard work over time.
And she's found that kids
with a growth mindset
tend to do better in school,
tend to have better jobs,
have better outcomes.
And so they actually have
a test at Manchester City
when they've been testing
kids for growth mindset.
Now, it's early days.
They say they've
had some success
in seeing a correlation
between players
who are shown from
this test to have
a growth mindset and the ones
who succeed in the academy.
So that's one attempt.
There have been
attempts by researchers
to look at a much sort of
broader array of personality
variables to try and
figure out what impact they
have on player success.
And they've been
able to identify
a bunch of different variables
that have an impact on success.
But any one of them only
measures kind of 1% to 2%.
And so personality is
such a complex thing
that I don't think they've
been able to isolate
one part of emotional
intelligence
that's going to really tell
them whether a kid's going
to make it.
But there was another
interesting study
that was done in Australia,
where they looked at grit.
Grit is another one of
these personality traits
that's been shown,
not just in soccer
but in a lot of
other facets in life,
that grittier kids
tend to succeed.
And they found
that with players,
that the grittier
players tend to play
more when they're young.
They tend to acquire
more game intelligence
and tend to be more successful.
But again, it's just one
component of personality.
Now, maybe as things like
advanced brain imaging
and things like that
become more powerful,
they'll be able to isolate it
in a way that's actually more
useful for decision-making.
But I think right
now, they haven't
been able to do
it in a way that's
quantitative enough for them
to really kind of use it
as a filter for these kids.
I think that the coaches
still think the best
way to do it is just
spend time with a kid
and see how they
react to failure,
see how they react to difficult
situations on and off the field
and go by that.
AUDIENCE: So there's
no immediate impact
to the NFL draft anytime soon?
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for the talk.
So I have actually
two questions.
One is, so it sounds like you
don't think this Qatar endeavor
experiment was a full success.
Or it could have been
a bigger success.
So the first question
is, what do you
think that Qatar got wrong?
And for example, would
the same endeavor
have been more successful
if it was conducted, say,
in a European country, right?
And the second question is,
if you can comment on doping.
Is there any doping
at these ages?
Do you have any--
what's the part of kind
of chemical supplements
in this part of the picture?
Does it come in into
these early ages?
Is it coming into
the picture later--
if you can comment on this.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Yeah, so I'll
take the second question first.
I don't think
doping is an issue,
at least with this kind of youth
scouting in Africa, it's not--
at least I never heard of it.
I don't think there would
be really the resources
to do a sort of sophisticated
doping program anyways.
In terms of the
first question, I
think they got a
couple of things wrong.
I think, one, the age
issue is a big one.
And I focus on the players at
the beginning of the program
that they found.
I'm not actually sure how much
better they got over time.
It may be that they got
much better over time
at determining players' ages.
But at least in terms of
the ones I focused on,
I think that was a
big handicap for them.
Because again, if
you're not picking
kids who are the age
you think they are,
then they're not as good
as you think they are.
And it doesn't necessarily
mean they won't succeed.
But it means that there
is a smaller probability
that they're going to succeed.
I think the other
thing that if I
were designing a program
like this and your outcome
was really just--
or your goal was really just
to produce star players--
they should have taken
more than 20 every year.
They should have
maybe spent less money
on sending the kids to
Europe to play and to Qatar
to go train at the academy
there, and just take
more kids into the program.
Because if you talk
to sport scientists,
they're often quite critical
of talent identification
at a young age in
soccer, because it's
so difficult to choose which
players have the potential.
They say that it's
better to keep
as many kids in the
system as possible
for a long period of time so
that they can weed them out
over time.
And there has been some
interesting research
on the German youth
national team,
where they found that,
on average, every year,
there's about 40% turnover in
the German youth national team.
So that shows you
that there is a lot
of changing opinions
about which players
they think are the best players.
They also found that
the younger you make it
on the team, the
lower your probability
that you make it
to the senior team.
And so the kids who they
think the best over time
are going to change.
And so the only
way to really deal!
With that is to have more kids
in the system and to let them
be weeded out over time.
SPEAKER: Well, thanks,
everyone, for being here.
Sebastian, thank you for coming.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT:
Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER: We have copies
of "The Away Game."
And Sebastian will be
signing at the end.
SEBASTIAN ABBOT: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]